I Lamar you are obviously so good at so
many different things on the field but I
have to ask fill in the blank the only
way to contain Lamar Jackson is to be
okay okay the most underrated position
in the NFL is a lot of people like
people know me to get him credit if I
had to the corner I would avoid throwing
to the most is Marcus shoes Marcus
Peters well why him what makes him so
good cause if he cheated like he played
receiver like back in the day so he
knows what's going on him if Lamar
Jackson played in the NBA his player
comparison would be well almost a horse
whisperer okay why Russell Westbrook oh
no because he's a little job in my
people bus and we take off go crazy
don't be explosive like could you have
been an NBA player if he worked at it
I'll see ya yeah not a shoe I know it
seems like there is always like a
Patrick mahomes Lamar Jackson debate
happening does it bother you that that's
that's always a topic a football to
differences window-shutters by Obama
yeah do you think it'll ever end
no I think you see that if you could
take one aspect of his game what would
it be
none you're like I'm Muammar don't need
it okay if
there is one okay okay so you would say
Paxman okay tell me about your
friendship with Drake what was it like
to see him you know have on the a in his
in his video he tell you comment well
gentlemen then I end up sitting on his
piece it was crazy I got me some juice
in it okay now I'm a big Drake fan so
I'm not a disbelief but many people will
claim it now you have the Drake curse
and the Madden curse going against you
what would you say to that does make a
positive okay now I like that answer two
negatives make a positive
will Lamar Jackson open Madden with a 99
overall Oh sir Lamar Jackson have a 99
overall rating what do you think you
should have a last year better than a 76
at the beginning of the season what
attributes you have that make you in 99
overall up to you if it was up to you
okay I'm gonna make you the GM I'm gonna
give you a position and name some
players and you pick the ones that would
be on your ultimate team okay all right
I'm gonna name five quarterbacks you get
to have two quarterbacks on your team
you got a pick two of these quarterbacks
okay
Michael Vick Russell Wilson pay
manning deshaun Watson Patrick mahomes
unless Harlan just oh all right
I'm gay okay
wide receivers you can pick three Randy
Moss DeAndre Hopkins Terrell Owens Julio
Jones Michael Thomas okay all right no
DeAndre Mike who running backs
you can pick two Christian McCaffrey say
qualms Barkley Ezekiel Elliott Bo
Jackson Barry Sanders not new guys okay
but y'all actually like super awesome
right it is what it is I'm gonna school
committee they already cross okay
you can pick one of the new guys
Christian McCaffrey sacrum Barkley is a
cue Elliot obviously I'm part of us a
Christian Christian well Mar Congrats on
the Madden cover that's huge and it's
not bad for a running back not at all
thanks for your time